I feel like if you know how to do it if
you have a feeling that you can solve
something then you better do it
otherwise this universe is going to take
it away from you
how did your parents risk their lives
for you and your brother
well we are they're from Vietnam so 1975
was communism and
um
there we we were so my background is
that my family's background we were rich
people like crazy Rich Asians you saw
the movie we were like that in Vietnam
and within that conversion 1975 everyone
went to zero so
my parents had told me that they it was
like a 50 50 or even 60 40 chance of
getting of dying to get us into a
different country
so we travel by the boat right and
Pirates and plundering and
you know murders happen why I'm in the
stomach of my mom
and so
um so
their goal was to ensure that we were
secured my brother and I and uh that
that they felt at the time there was no
hope in Vietnam
and so they did everything they can they
said they were rally die always die then
to suffer in Vietnam in feeling that we
were going to be imprisoned
and so you traveled to the U.S and you
landed where so I was born in Thailand
so we went to Thailand and then you know
and then uh and then six months later I
came to America
but during that time my mom had uh
post-traumatic stress and even developed
slight schizophrenia and um and then
later on the you know the
Whatchamacallit the the people took us
into a foster care so I was with foster
care right so my parents my second
parents were Irish and Italian
and that's where I learned how to play
the piano I learned the American
cultures do that I learned a lot of type
of stuff and um
yeah so that was my upbringing and then
my parents and you know so think about
this we came from
going into the country with no money
going into a family that had a lot of
money and then about two years later go
back to a family back into the ghetto
only to survive again learn how to
survive and we went from being
um
you know my foster parents are very
loving people right and um and then
going to the back going back to home in
Jersey City and it was really really bad
back there so one of the worst cities in
America
it's a
um my parents were working 12-hour days
so I don't get to see my parents at all
that's my life that's my that's my
brother and I I'll bring you
how long were you I guess was it called
a ward of the court or you were with
these foster parents yeah they were
forced until my mom got better you know
they had to show proof that my mom had
to have the paper say that she's good
she you know she's as long she's on the
pills which she's still on today
you know
um she has to be on pills so she
suppresses her anger on things
so you were there a year six months or
oh for my foster parents I was there for
about almost two years two years wow
okay without my parents yeah and then
once they were in Jersey City then you
went back to live with them and now
you're getting acclimated to New Jersey
life yeah that's pretty much it yeah
yeah I mean
um you know my brother has the worst
story because he's experienced racism
right and his story was you know he
would get chased by the white folks when
he was in the privileged neighborhood
and then he comes over here he gets
minorities injured everyone is a
minority in Jersey City but we're all
racist to each other
you know and that was the um and uh but
then you know I mean you know like in
high school when I get it was a fight
every day a shoot a stabbing once a once
a week in the shooting once a month no
news no media that's the norm and that's
the school I went to that's just put in
perspective
and so was there a time where you were
in high school where you said I don't
want to stay here I want to leave you
know I did I didn't know there was
another life
the most I've seen was TV
you know what I'm saying like I never
went into the most of it is going to New
York City and jersey in life but and
then that that that that life in in
foster care was so like a blur to me
that I don't remember God was the sort
of baby when I was back there and so
um I thought that my life was gonna be
that you know always living in danger
all the time
how often do you think about those early
stages in your life and then What
feelings are attached to those memories
you know I think about every day
I got two kids and I think of how
privileged they are you know and I think
it's it's the thing that feels me I
still work 12 to 14 hours a day you know
why it's because of those memories it's
the it's the
it's
it's being able to have
is my parents I think about my parents
giving us this shot at life
and for some reason I received all this
these gifts
abilities the capabilities that I have
in my pinky that most people I do know
that you know technologically uh
business-wise music and everything else
and I feel like
it was not given to me by an accident it
was given to me for a reason and I feel
like
um I put a lot of weight on my shoulder
to
um go ahead and try to
um make the most out of it
and I always feel this way I feel like
if you know how to do it if you have a
feeling that you could solve something
then you better do it otherwise this
universe is going to take it away from
you
and your brother is where my brother is
uh he lives in in
um Jersey in Central Jersey and he's a
software developer with nothing like me
at all zero uh you know he's a
programmer
like no Sports not into sports 19 music
90 films nothing like that but he's very
supportive he's a protective brother
yeah
what would you say is the best thing or
some of the best things that came from
humble beginnings
um understanding how to build something
from scratch from nothing
I think that is a gift
I think that
um you get perspective around
not judging people
um no matter where they come from you
try not to judge them at least or you
consider if you think something wrong
you might you might think something else
around like okay there's a reason why
they stole something at the store you
know it doesn't mean that bad people
they just be able to survive so I think
of it that way
um I look at it as
um you know
career speaking wise for me I look at it
as it's uh
because I came from nothing I was forced
to solve problems from you know like
you know take uh you know I guess so
it's you could give me anything uh that
and I'll be able to figure out how to
solve it and that's what it was like
it's like kind of like your
um
you know it's uh
I don't know I I would say like any
problems we had so many problems and so
many
um adversity in life that that money was
not the answer because we didn't have
any
so you figure out how to solve it and
you figure out how to do it efficiently
you figure out how to do it with uh with
other people collaboratively with people
and then you figure out how to
um do it again
and and I feel like how that affected me
for today was well I mean it's how I
created full feature films
built two businesses three businesses at
the moment and and you know and be able
to
survive through it and be able to come
out something that's
almost what people consider almost
impossibly uh impossible to to you know
to see through
so it made you resourceful well 100 is
resourceful yeah you think it also you
weren't as afraid of risk
[Music]
I'm always afraid of risk always afraid
of risk
um
I'm more afraid of disappointment from
the risk
you know
um you know like I think just naturally
I'm I don't want my parents just being
disappointed in me and I want my friends
disappointed me I think that it's this
you know like unlike someone like
garyvee or someone would say don't think
who cares what people think about you
I'm the complete opposite where I care
what the people that love me think about
me
because they work so hard to get me to a
place to uh um to get to me to a place
to have certain opportunities and I wish
to kind of squander that then it's
almost selfish of me that I think the
lookout for them
that's how I kind of look at it even
though they might not be thinking that
but my mind always goes to that for some
reason
and it keeps me fired up